this video was brought to you by talk in
Arabic the only place where you can
learn any of the major dialects of
spoken Arabic if you want to learn
Arabic the way it's really spoken click
the link in the description to visit
talk in
Arabic of the many dialects of the
Arabic language spoken across the Arab
world the most widely understood is
probably Egyptian Arabic in particular
the variety spoken in Cairo why well
Egypt is by far the most populous Arab
country with 110 million people and
Cairo is by far the largest Arab City
with around 22 million people living in
its metropolitan area throughout the
20th century it was the main center of
the Arab world's movie industry and
music industry this familiarized Arabic
speakers everywhere with the dialect of
Cairo though in the internet era the
Egyptian Arabic of Cairo has become
somewhat less dominant in media it's
still widely understood and is probably
the most popular dialect for Learners of
Arabic who cares what does it matter
what dialect I learn well Standard
Arabic which nobody speaks in formally
is fairly different from any dialect and
the dialects are all somewhat different
from each other even though native
speakers of Arabic can generally
understand each other by adjusting their
speech you still need to choose one
variety to focus on learning well most
students of Arabic learn two Modern
Standard Arabic for literacy and formal
speech and a dialect for everyday speech
but if you're not that serious about
learning Arabic over the long term then
focusing on a popular dialect like
Egyptian Arabic will serve you just fine
as in most other parts of the Arab world
Arabic became spoken in Egypt after the
Arab conquest of the 7th Century before
that the native inhabitants of Egypt
mainly spoke Coptic a language which
descended from ancient Egyptian it's
still used as a lurgical language by
Coptic Christians but their language of
everyday communication is Egyptian
Arabic Egyptian Arabic was influenced by
Coptic though as Coptic speakers adopted
the newly dominant language imagine your
country was suddenly conquered by a
foreign power and you had to learn their
language do you think you would learn to
speak speak it exactly the way they
spoke it probably not especially if you
had to learn it in a hurry Coptic is not
the only language that has influenced
Egyptian Arabic it was also influenced
by Turkish because Egypt was ruled by
the Ottoman Empire for hundreds of years
it was also influenced by French because
Egypt was occupied by Napoleon's Army
for a short time but more so because
French was the major international
language of the 19th and early 20th
centuries as Egypt modernized it adopted
many new words from French its
vocabulary was also in influenced by
Italian during that time as a result of
increased trade with Italy and the
migration of tens of thousands of
Italians to Egypt and of course it was
also influenced by Greek which had been
the administrative language for
centuries before the Arab Conquest some
of this influence came indirectly from
Coptic which adopted many Greek lone
words during that time and as with Italy
trade with Greece and migration of
Greeks to Egypt in the 19th and early
20th centuries resulted in the adoption
of more Greek vocabulary of course
Egyptian Arabic is mainly Arabic but
these influences are part of what give
it its unique flavor that sets it apart
from Standard Arabic and from other
dialects pronunciation there's one
particular consonant in Egyptian Arabic
which gives you a big hint that you're
likely hearing the Egyptian dialect
pronunciation of the consonant J as G
rather than J or for example the word
for mountain ja is pronounced gab the
word for Camel jaml is pronounced gaml
the word for crazy m is pronounced
magnon and so on some people theorize
that pronouncing gim as G comes from the
influence of the Coptic language but
this pronunciation also appears in some
dialects of Yemen and Oman while it
doesn't appear in the Sidi dialect of
Southern Egypt even though Coptic was
used there so the Gus sound might come
from certain Arabic tribes who were most
numerous among the soldiers or settlers
in Northern Egypt around the time of the
conquest it's quite clear that in protos
Semitic the original equivalent of Jim
was pronounced g a pronunciation which
was preserved in Aramaic Hebrew and some
other Semitic languages so in Hebrew
camel is pronounced gal similar to
Egyptian Arabic G so even though in the
classical Arabic of the Quran Jim is
pronounced some dialects of that time
probably retained the original G and
maybe that's where Egypt got its G sound
lots of other Arabic dialects do have a
g sound but it's usually not for the
letter Jim it's for the letter cof in
Standard Arabic this is like a C Sound
but articul it further back in your
mouth so the standard word for pen is
pronounced in those accents but in
Northern Egypt it's pronounced the
consonant is normally replaced with a
glottal stop in Egyptian Arabic for
example the word for
heart
becomes the word from Moon
becomes and so on this is also the case
for most speakers of letine dialects
meaning Lebanese Syrian Jordanian and
Palestinian and like in many other
dialects The interdental fricative
Sounds th andth are normally not
pronounced in Egyptian Arabic in older
words native to the dialect they're
pronounced T and D the word for heavy
becomes and notice again that is
pronounced as a glottal stop the word
for gold
becomes there are other cases when th
becomes s and the becomes Z for example
the word for student or
pupil becomes
but in general they're pronounced s and
z in words borrowed into the dialect
more recently from Modern Standard
Arabic the word for
revolution
becomes the word for graceful
becomes the emphatic interdental sound
becomes like an emphatic D or the word
for
noon
becomes the word for unjust or
oppressive becomes
there are also some differences in
vowels in Egyptian Arabic though these
may not be as obvious as the consonants
lots of unstressed vowels get reduced or
deleted take the word meaning she
traveled in Standard Arabic
it's in Egyptian Arabic it's sa notice
that the vowel of the second syllable is
deleted forming a consonant cluster with
the beginning of the next syllable
instead and notice that the vowel of the
final syllable is reduced to
I also notice that the long a vowel is
shortened when followed by a consonant
cluster long vowels are also shortened
when a suffix is added immediately after
the long vowel or the suffix causes the
long vowel to be unstressed the third
person singular past tense verb meaning
he slept is if you make it negative in
Egyptian Arabic
it's the sh suffix at the end shortens
the long a vowel that comes before it
the verb meaning to see
is when you form the second person
singular masculine past tense form by
adding the suffix to
it's which means you saw in the
masculine singular or with the rising
intonation you hear in the audio did you
see as a question notice that the long
oo is shortened let's add an object
suffix shuft plus
KN this means you masculine singular saw
me when the suffix NE is added it
results in a cluster of three consonants
but remember in Egyptian Arabic that's
not allowed so a short vowel is inserted
the vowel matches the one in the suffix
a little side note in Standard Arabic
this pronoun is an the Egyptian pronouns
are similar to Standard Arabic but
slightly different let's try a different
object
suffix this means you masculine singular
saw her notice the a vowel that's
inserted after the first two consonants
and before the third one it matches the
vowel in the suffix something similar
happens when a word ends in a two
consonant cluster and the next word
begins with a
consonant this means I was sleeping
notice that a schw vowel comes between
and this prevents having three
consonants in a row without a vowel in
Standard Arabic there are 14 Sun
consonants that assimilate to the
definite article for example Al plus sh
meaning Sun becomes a in Egyptian Arabic
the definite article is rather than Al
so
it's but in Egyptian Arabic several
additional consonants can assimilate to
the definite article to
G and C when it's pronounced in the
standard way and not as a glottal stop
for example meaning the mountain can
be meaning the word can be and so on
this is something you might hear in
casual speech but is not always used
vocabulary Egyptian Arabic has numerous
words and expressions that stand out as
typically Egyptian many of these words
are also found in Standard Arabic and in
other varieties of Arabic but are used
more frequently or used differently in
Egyptian Arabic in Standard Arabic and
in many dialects the way to ask how are
you
is when speaking to a man and when
speaking to a woman literally it's how's
your condition or in more strict
literary use with case
endings but in Egyptian Arabic the way
to ask how are you to a man is is or to
a woman is
is is the question word meaning how with
a personal pronoun suffix honk honk beep
beep in the Arabic audio samples you
might hear a lot of cars honking their
horns sorry about the noise but the
samples were recorded in Cairo and
that's exactly what Cairo sounds like so
I hope you can enjoy the Ambiance of
Cairo rather than be annoyed by it
anyways back to the video you might also
hear I'm literally doing what this is
like asking what are you doing or what
are you up to the question word for what
in Standard Arabic is or Ma and in
different dialects you'll hear different
words for what
likeu and so on in Egyptian Arabic the
typical word is it comes from Standard
Arabic a meaning which what's your
name to a man and is to a woman what is
this the in Standard Arabic the words
for this are
and in Egyptian Arabic there and
but back
to how are you the typical Egyptian way
to answer when someone asks how you are
is qu for a man or qua for a woman which
means good fine or Nice in Standard
Arabic you'll likely he and in other
dialects Z or other words in Egyptian
Arabic is sometimes used but it's
pronounced like
this notice that the diff thongs of
Modern Standard Arabic are normally
pronounced anounced as simple vowels in
Egyptian
dialect you'll almost certainly hear
Egyptians
say which means very good or very nice
and can also be used as an exclamation
to show enthusiasm or to respond
favorably to something like awesome or
wow that's
great comes from the Arabic word which
means strong the sound is usually
pronounced as a glot stop in Egyptian
Arabic like I mentioned before but
Egyptians pronounce this word with a
sound when it has the original meaning
of
strong this is very expensive in
Standard Arabic it would
be where are you going when said to a
man
or when said to a woman in Standard
Arabic it would
be to a man
or the Egyptian word for where is it
comes from Standard
Arabic which literally means in where
the participle form of comes from
classical Arabic but is more widely used
in Arabic dialects including Egyptian
whereas the most common verb meaning to
go in Modern Standard Arabic
is I'm going to the store now the
Egyptian word for now comes from
classical
Arabic which means at this time in
Standard Arabic the usual word for now
is
also notice that the preposition IL is
usually dropped in Egyptian Arabic while
it isn't in Standard
Arabic I want to buy some new clothes
word for word I want I buy clothes new
another typically Egyptian word is or to
mean want this word comes from a
classical Arabic verb but now is mainly
used in Egyptian Arabic the usual verb
in Standard Arabic is
AR and
the standard word for clothes is and
Egyptians use this word too but a
typically Egyptian word for clothes is H
those are some words that are
characteristic of Egyptian Arabic but
there are also lone words from other
languages like I mentioned before there
are a small number of words of Coptic
origin like gibna Hali meaning cream
cheese gibna is the Arabic word for
cheese while the base of this word halum
comes from the Coptic word for cheese
another word is the word for
toel one Coptic word that made its way
into Standard Arabic and other dialects
is meaning
Oasis there are numerous words that were
borrowed from Turkish during the time of
the Ottoman Empire there's the word for
room that's in contrast with the
standard word for
room there's the word for bridge that's
in contrast with the standard word
there's the word for shoe GMA that's in
contrast with the standard word
the plural form of gzma is gizm but for
a pair of shoes the singular form is
used there's the word for closet or
cupboard and so on there are numerous
French words as well the word for
elevator the word for diet regime the
word for lady or miss
m there are numerous words related to
automobiles that were boiled from French
because automotive technology developed
during the times of French prominence
the word for steering
wheel from
French meaning Direction the word for
Hood kab the word for accelerator
ex there are some words from Italian as
well the word for
bathtub the word for furniture Mia the
word for glove guanti the word for fake
in reference to Goods FAL there's the
expression from Italian St this means
it's fine but is used in Egyptian Arabic
like like it's a
deal then there are words of Greek
origin the word for
table from Greek trap the word for
strawberry from greeka and so on there
are also a few features of Egyptian
Arabic grammar that differ from Standard
Arabic and from other dialects in
questions in Egyptian Arabic the
question word tends to come at the end
of the question for example is or is
what's your name word for word name your
what in Standard Arabic this would
be
or and in other dialects it might
be Isis and so on some say that this
syntax comes from the influence of
Coptic though this is not universally
accepted another difference in syntax is
the position of demonstrative adjectives
after the noun they modify for
example this house word for word the
house this in Standard Arabic this would
be this the
house the city word for word the city
this in Standard Arabic this would
be this the
city as in dialects in general Egyptian
Arabic has certain prefixes that are
added to the imperfect form of a verb to
indicate present tense or future tense
the imperfect verb form plus the prefix
B indicates present tense as in letine
dialects it can be used for habitual
present he smokes cigarettes and it can
be used for present
continuous he's smoking a cigarette in
Standard Arabic the present tense would
normally be the imperfect form with no
prefix the potentially confusing thing
about this prefix is that in most
dialects of the Arabian Peninsula it
indicates future tense not present tense
in Egyptian Arabic the future tense is
indicated by the imperfect form plus the
prefix or the increasingly common
variant he's traveling to Jordan
tomorrow moral I know the English
sentence is written in the present
continuous form but we use that with
future meaning for things that are
already planned or scheduled in Standard
Arabic the verb would be used with the
suffix or the future tense marker sa
before the
verb and notice that the usual word for
tomorrow in Egyptian Arabic is which
comes from classical Arabic and is used
in many dialects but it's not the usual
word in Modern Standard Arabic instead
the word
is typically used another difference in
grammar between Egyptian Arabic and
Modern Standard Arabic is that Egyptian
Arabic has no dual verb forms in Modern
Standard Arabic and of course in
classical Arabic there are special verb
conjugations used when the subject is a
pair of people or things but in Egyptian
you just use the regular plural
conjugations but this is the case for
dialects in general so it's no big
surprise of course Egyptian Arabic also
has many of its own slang expressions
and colorful idioms here are a few
examples
this literally means stay heavy or be
heavy but it's used with the meaning of
hold on or be patient the word moot
which means death can be used as an
intensifier like very or
really this means a very difficult
exam
or this means I really love you it's
kind of like how in English you can say
you love someone to death another
expression that can be used as an
intensifier is which means equal to the
world or equivalent to the
world he's very famous in other words at
the highest level of Fame notice that in
Egyptian Arabic the word da meaning this
can be used with the meaning of
he but I lost respect for him this
literally means but he came down from my
eye he has Bad Manners literally his
manners are bad the phrase literally
means not as much but is used with the
meaning of bad I'm sure you'll agree
that Egyptian Arabic is a fascinating
and expressive variety of the Arabic
language that reflects the history and
personality of the Egyptian people and
with its Central position in Arab media
entertainment and pop culture there's no
wonder it's the most widely studied
Arabic dialect if you're a speaker of
Egyptian Arabic what other typically
Egyptian words or Expressions would you
like us to know and if you speak a
different variety of Arabic how do you
view the Egyptian dialect do you see it
as more influential or prestigious than
other dialects or is it just one of many
if you're learning Arabic there's a
special and unique program that I think
you should check out it's called talk in
Arabic and it's the only place where you
can learn any of the major dialects of
spoken Arabic they have lessons
resources and HD videos covering each
variety so you can focus on whichever
variety you're learning but you can also
gain exposure to the other varieties
build an awareness of the differences
and improve your listening comprehension
of spoken Arabic in general to check out
talk in Arabic click the link in the
description you can use my code Lang
Focus for a 10% discount off any
plan and now it's time to say thanks to
the Lang Focus patreon supporters
especially the ones whose names appear
on the screen they are the top tier
patreon supporters so let's give them a
round of
applause if you liked this video then
check out my playlist of videos on the
Arabic language you'll find more videos
like this about various varieties of
Arabic as well as different topics
involving the Arabic language